on poursuit cette semaine encore notre
série de reportages consacrée à la
gestion de l'eau en agriculture
aujourd'hui on vous présente un
dispositif innovant et mis au point par
le centre de recherche de l'inrae à
Nouzilly il s'agit d'une rampe
d'irrigation intelligente qui délivre
plus ou moins d'eau en fonction des sols
qu'elle doit asperger plus
d'explications dans ce reportage de
Florent Clavel
[Musique]
comme un gros brumisateur sauf que de
sous c'est du soja sur ce site de
l'inrae à nous y cette rampe
d'irrigation distille l'eau qu'on goûte
presque de manière millimétrée et c'est
là toute la nouveauté qui est testée en
ce moment sur cette parcelle de 30
hectares on va pouvoir
à peu près 6 à la fois parce qu'on gère
l'avancée de la rampe et à la fois parce
qu'on gère la quantité d'eau qui arrive
au buse alors qu'elle n'est pratique que
sur 6% des surfaces agricoles françaises
l'irrigation représente 80% des
prélèvements cette installation
permettrait les économies d'eau de
l'ordre de 30% avec en prime un arrosage
sur-mesure en fonction de la nature des
sols et de la plante l'idée c'est
effectivement de développer des
pratiques d'irrigations qui permettent
d'avoir des essais d'irrigation très
localisés de faire ce qu'on appelle de
l'irrigation de résilience donc pour
éviter que les plantes qui sont fragiles
mais moins gourmandes en eau et bien et
des problèmes de lever donc on va
l'utiliser beaucoup pour ça le but c'est
d'arroser plutôt exactement ce dont
chaque morceau de la parcelle a besoin
la commercialisation de cette rampe
pourrait intervenir d'ici 3 à 5 ans
reste un obstacle de taille son cou
entre 100 et 150000 euros encore faut-il
que les agriculteurs s'y retrouvent